♪♪
Oh, it's so nice to be back.
I love the show. It's a
wonderful cast.
It's like being home surrounded
by the best of the biz.
Oh yeah, no, I'm sick of
everybody.
But not as sick as they're of
me.
♪♪
I feel so grateful that we get
to do another season of this
show.
It's just been the best.
This season Ian and Poppy
have broken out on their own.
Charlotte Nicdao:
They're building their own game.
Ian's working on Poppy's game,
instead of the other way around.
Megan Ganz:
Most of the season is
spent exploring how
their partnership withstands
that new dynamic.
I can't work like this.
-We we.
It's clear that we all can't
work like this.
-We.
Work like what?
But back at Mythic Quest, David
is doing his best to keep things
under control with finally
a helpful assistant in Jo.
Celebrate this man!
Don't force it.
David has taken over Mythic
Quest.
Which is on time and on budget.
You have a meeting in five
minutes, boss.
I sure do.
(sighs)
Charlotte Nicdao:
Brad, has just gotten out of
prison.
I was like, how are we gonna
get out? Am I gonna come out
with neck tattoos? Like, what's the deal here?
He's our new janitor.
I'm excited to get cleaning.
Okay.
I'm really excited for people
to see Poppy and Ian's,
"GRIMMPOP".
I think it's like a really great
new space.
It sort of has this futuristic and
minimalistic feel to it.
Office... "cyan".
(Robotic-voice)
Cyan.
Yeah, yeah.
-That's nice.
-That's nice. That is nice.
I'm really excited for everyone
to get to see these characters
outside of the
Imani Hakim:
original appearance that we've
gotten to know them as.
You know what, this, is weird.
I think a lot of people thought
that maybe the end of season two
was like, wrapping things up,
Charlotte Nicadao:
but wow, there's so many more
adventures that we have to do.
If you already love "MQ", you're
gonna get the same lol's, Okay.
If you're new to "MQ", you're
getting, some fun, funky fresh
characters,
that you didn't even know you
needed in your life.
You're welcome.
Wooo!
Woohoo! Rejoice!
Jo:
Haha.
Rejoice!
♪♪